all right the fifth year option deadline
for the 2017 first round picks in the
nfl draft arrives today we know
all but one of them i believe we know
all of them in the top ten and look not
that long ago i was making the point
chris that
uh
the draft is a crap shoot and as the
first round is unfolding and you're
hearing from all the draft analysts how
great these guys are no one ever says oh
you know what half of these guys are
gonna stink
and look at the top 10 from 2017 half of
the guys are not having their fifth year
option picked up which means
they stink
all due respect they aren't what they
were believed to be when they were made
top 10 picks this is the prime example
of that dynamic that you and your dad
were talking about last week where guys
show up at the nfl and it's grown ass
men and some guys respond and some guys
never do and half of the top 10 not
responding to the level where their
teams view it as a no-brainer to take
that fifth year option no i mean hey
mike i mean you're right i mean there's
no doubt as we know it's it's calculated
risk calculated you know assessments as
far as the draft is concerned you know
and and i don't know if a lot of people
realize this but the success rate for
second and third round picks is i i
believe still it was at least to like a
year ago greater than the first round
picks so you know a lot of the times
these top 10 picks top 20 picks are
drafted on potential or having a special
trait that the nfl looked at and said oh
i like this special trait this guy has i
think i can make this trait into a
superstar player and within that you're
gonna have bus sometimes and that this
you know that draft we're talking about
uh is certainly underwhelming when you
start to get into those names you know
and i think some of them are
questionable at the time they really
were um but it's the way the draft fell
out that year and yeah i'm not shocked
by any of these are you mike i mean
the only one i could sit here and go a
little bit i thought maybe leonard
fournette had a chance but because of
what he's done off the field and you
know spouting off against cam newton i
think they're probably a little sick of
his antics you know other than that i'm
not i'm not shocked by any of these
other you know these names as far as
trubisky thomas fournette davis and ross
are concerned
yeah i mean between the concerns about
leonard fournette being a pain in the
butt for the folks in jacksonville and
they tried to trade him and maybe would
still like to try to trade him and maybe
he is more tradable with only one year
left on his contract and not that fifth
year option that is guaranteed for
injury and of all the positions running
back is the one where you could get a
serious injury that and here's how it
works any injury he would have this year
that would keep him from passing a
physical before the start of the next
league year when this money becomes
fully guaranteed you can't cut him if he
can't pass a physical therefore
you are stuck you can't cut him if he
can't pass a physical because his salary
is guaranteed for injury it then becomes
fully guaranteed next march bottom line
is you're stuck with that salary whether
you have him on the team or not that is
why so many of these teams are shying
away from picking up these options
because
look it does give you control of the guy
for one more year but you carry around
that risk that let's say we get to week
17 and there's some sort of injury that
happens then and he has to have surgery
and if you can't pass that physical
before the start of the league year in
march you are stuck with that full
salary that's why washington had rg3 in
bubble wrap for all of the 2015 season
when kirk cousins became the
unquestioned starter they did not want
rg3 to get injured and then have that
injury guaranteed salary for the next
year uh wrapped uh you know up in their
in their uh their salary cap and also
the cash commitments so that that's why
you just don't pick up the option you
just don't do it and that's why half of
the guys in the top ten didn't have
their options picked up chris
no that's right they're they're not
worth it you know and to what you're
saying with the running back position
mike i'll just even further it to where
yeah you don't make
you don't exercise the fifth year option
unless you're just totally sold on the
guy and oh man we know he's gonna be
here for three or four more years you
know with a guy like leonard fournette
too where i'll just throw in listen to
the conversation for food for thought
you know with these running backs and
their short shelf lives too
you know if you're jacksonville and
leonard fournette is on your roster to
start the season and starts to put
together a really good year
you know week eight week ten coming
around you dangle out a big contract for
some of these running backs i i don't
think they're gonna it's hard for them
to turn around turn it down when you're
playing that physical position too so
it's not like jacksonville's dead and
gone
just because they didn't fit your option
leonard fournette and this is totally
not you know done forever you know again
like i said i think if leonard
fournette's playing like one of the best
running backs in football and they throw
out you know
nine ten million dollars a year type
contract with some guarantee for a few
years that sues them over you know i
think most running backs and football
are gonna are gonna bite the hook on
that one and go you know what i'll take
it it's security right now it's cash in
my pocket i got seven more games to go
this season and i know i play running
back and a lot of bad things can happen
too so i think that empowers at least
teams in the organizational standpoint
at the running back position in these
type of conversations
assuming fournette fits with the new jay
gruden offense in jackson i'm not so
sure he does which i think is one of the
reasons one of the many reasons why they
were thinking about trying to trade him
as it relates to mitchell trubisky big
cat and i were talking about this on
friday because he's a big bears fan and
i think he's conflicted about what's
happening with trubisky but you know the
best case scenario for the bears really
would be
to have between the presence of nick
foles and the decision not to pick up
the fifth year option for trubisky be
that thing that really wakes him up and
to have trubisky win the starting job
over nick foles nick foles would be one
hell of a great teammate one great
backup a great insurance policy in the
event trubisky got injured and then
trubisky has a surprisingly good year
good problem to have if you're the bears
that you don't have the guy under the
fifth year option for 2021. i mean look
the worst case scenario would be having
to use the franchise tag on him next
year and i don't think he's going to
play so well that that would be in play
but you know sometimes you can wake a
guy up by not using the fifth year
option remember when the buccaneers had
doug martin under contract and didn't
pick up his fifth year option and he had
a great contract year and they had to
sign him to a much larger money deal
chris that can happen and you know what
good problem to have if this is the
thing that finally gets the guy
to be the guy that we thought he was
going to be so be it
yeah the big thing is you know again
this is a team that went 12-4 with him
just two years ago what if he goes 12-4
again right and you know doesn't play
like one of the top five quarterbacks in
football but plays good football you
know to like what you're saying and all
of a sudden you go oh okay well what are
you gonna do you're gonna just ship them
you know down the river and go oh we're
gonna get somebody else new you know
listen i feel bad for mitchell trubisky
in a lot of ways you know one his rookie
year he got part of a a chicago bears
team at that point that they you know
did did him an injustice with the talent
they had around them i mean mike they
were starting games that year his rookie
year with tariq cohen at cohn as one of
their starting receivers not running
back not third down running back they
would come out and play two running
backs one tight end and two receivers
and the roster failed mitchell trubisky
to such a such a drastic point that they
had to make terry cohn one of the
starting receivers you know then year
two he gets with matt maggie things go
well year three all right yeah the team
had some issues last year the offense
stunk it fell apart it never changed
from the year and trubisky didn't play
well so
i i do feel bad for him i do and i think
he gets a lot of crap because of where a
team drafted him he didn't ask to be
drafted before mahomes and watson
but i certainly understand the bearish
decision here
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports